our services still off-limits to me what
do you need guns lots of guns you think
you can take John wick you got a nasty
surprise coming how do you go about
turning up the action in a series that's
defined by its turned up action and how
involved are you it may be
conceptualizing some of these fights
um the conceptualizing will I had a
wonderful director and visionary and
chats to hell ski so just really I my
job is just to try and do as best I can
so that you know his vision will be here
and I have to I'm really the limit like
as much as I can do that's as good as
it's you know so for me it's great to
try and aspire to the to that vision is
there something you got to gut do in
this film that you've never done as an
actor before and you did it and you were
like ticked off that box yeah I mean to
the action point we were trying to do
John wick action but also I think build
it up do different things and so there's
more complexity more multiple people
fighting and then we have different
events so we have fighting on
motorcycles and to your question I would
say the horseback riding fight sequence
cuz that was involved some trick riding
what was was that the most challenging
scene for you the horse um from a pure I
didn't know how to do that distance to
like what I started with to like what I
had to do that was probably the greatest
distance there's a sequence in there for
the knife fight which was probably the
most physically intensive why do you
think these movies resonate with people
so much I mean here we are you're
already on the third one I feel like
there's gonna be a fourth one why do you
think people love him so much
I don't know but I'm really grateful and
happy that some people like it um yeah
I'm
I know why I like it I mean I think
people when I speak to people about it
they love the world they love the world
of continental the characters that
inhabit the world that action I think
people like rooting for John wick yeah
I'm so I would say and of course the dog
if John wick discovered a time-traveling
phone booth what do you think you'd do
with it
wherever John go what would he do
where's John wick I think maybe he would
go back to that time he spent with Helen
and just keep looping that just keep
doing the five and then trying to come
up for a cure for what ails her you
shouldn't be here
good to see you too we are when you have
a series s define by amped up action how
do you go about amping up the action
even more and where does that start does
it start on sort of where the story
logically goes or do you look and say
what kind of fight has John wick not got
into it's in this movie no honestly it's
a little of both it's mostly where the
story takes you and it's a lot of
research just you know we go to a city
we'll walk around New York American or
Canadian inspired by things my
grandfather when we were growing up in
Boston would take me to antique stores
so I just thought wouldn't it be cool if
you walked into an antique store and
picked up the stuff and started fighting
so we had this idea in Massachusetts a
springfield national armory where you
walking it's like a mini version of the
met we walk through the muskets the
rifles the swords we're like that let's
do one of those
wait is a horse come from we just
thought can't look really bitchin on a
horse haiman right but we both loved
westerns so I thought that would be
really fun and Hallie what did you see
that convinced you to be in this film
had you been searching for a badass role
were you a fan of the first two and you
will like get me into this franchise
somewhere that's what it was because
when I met with Chad my role hadn't been
to find you really or wasn't really
written in the way it became
hmm but I was a fan of 1 & 2 and I just
heard that Chad was doing three and he
was looking for a female character that
was kind of badass and I thought well
let me call me Chad so I went into Chad
and I said ah and I said I I'm gonna
play this part and it must have been it
was I I know that you it was a lot of
training and the dogs and I mean was
that is that the one of the most
challenging things you've ever done in
your career was the most challenging the
most physically challenging thing I've
ever done in my career for sure I mean I
broke three ribs along the way hey kind
of didn't stop into John's credit he
just gave I thought okay they're gonna
replace me now and he'd let me he'll
come back
nobody's messing with Halle Berry disco
you know but I've been speaking of her
character I do feel like this character
of all the characters that have been
introduced could kind of go off and spin
off and we can get get her home or her
own movie is that something that you
guys I've loved like two two opposing
characters - I always loved common and
the second John wick and I love Sophia
and the third gentleman I think those
are two - my favorite characters outside
of Johnny what do you think a heli for
sure I think Sophia should have her own
spin-off
there's so much to learn about Sophia
and there's so many more badass fights
that are in me yeah I definitely think
we should happen I feel bad for the
stunt teams where where would you
personally like to see sort of John wick
this franchise go from here it's always
fun to branch off I like world expansion
to see spin-offs to see different
characters take the road and then
intertwine back to John wick I think
John we can take you a certain direction
through our world but it'd be nice to
have other characters to kind of give
you different aspects of our world as
well take you through different routes I
think that'd be really fun and Hallie
have you thought about when your
character is not you know killing people
what she's doing in her spare time
bubble baths in you yoga see he hasn't
seen Instagram he's not into 2020
hidden does not know about Instagram or
my Instagram but Sophia yeah they do I
think Sophia you know she seems to be a
badass in this movie but I think she
so she has a big heart she has a
conscience I think she's living for
something greater than herself
like any of the characters in this
series are actually do you expected to
meet the dogs at 14 million dollar
bounty on his head every would the city
wants a piece of it I say the author
about even
all right so gentlemen tell me if four
moviegoers going into this film what is
John wick three deliver that maybe the
first two did not have the same and
different yeah well it is good it's more
you expect what what do you expect I
mean every boy just when they go and see
the third version of film you don't want
to change the subjects entirely but you
want more the same but you want a
difference somewhere so you're getting
to know more about Lance's character
which is terrific and you get to know
more because we've never you know you
might have think we've met in the film
if what we have on the phone to each
other and you talk a lot but we actually
and you understand our relationship with
John which is he's our favorite assassin
and we'll break the rules for him a
little bit more than anyone else I mean
I gave her an hour fisherman gave him a
weapon and uh and since then it's all
downhill from and once the high table
starts threatening me not a good idea is
Ronis good I mean also I think you get
to know more about the plot wise and
with the addition of you know the grand
jelica Houston I mean it's you know
there's the background which will lead
later on to you know
Halle Berry another good addition to it
so you get yeah bigger better more
beautiful white less why do you think
these films resonate so much with people
I mean we're already on the third
chapter you know why do you think
they're so successful there's so for an
action film to be so character driven um
well first of all I'm good but just just
cameras captured something about John's
character that you just watching it you
just love the guy you identify with him
so you identify from the beginning is
even though he's a badass to kick
everybody's ass in anywhere anytime
there's a vulnerability to him and
that's always kind of driving what he's
doing at least from the point that we
first meet him in the first oh yeah
there's a great but Carrie was just sort
of a strangely attractive melancholia
plus a relentlessness plus it's a deep
attractiveness to as a as a as a person
on screen he has that quality which he's
in real life he's one of the nicest god
terrific guy to work with terrific going
to me and he translates that into this
character and having a dead wife and a
puppy and his cat on his losing his car
three things a man could not do without
it that's how he says how far would you
guys go to save your pet are you pet
owners yes well yeah how far would you
go to save your pet uh I mean as far as
I need to go I'd like to think I
wouldn't have to kill anybody but I mean
so much trying to kill my dog I mean
when I take the water for my goldfish
every week we're not Saban
so you do affect know I travel didn't
know he said you travel always Hampton
huh when I was yeah when I was younger I
did a rabbit when I was like five no it
I was like I'm through and he died on me
so I was there we could keep this up as
long as you'd like but this only ends
[Music]
all right so people are gonna go see
this movie that maybe didn't see the
first two John wick movies and so for
somebody who wants to come in clean and
say I'm gonna go see John wick three
haven't seen the first two what would be
your message to them how would you
describe this movie bring a seat belt
yeah yeah no go well I haven't seen the
finished movie but from what I've heard
yeah make sure that you have some time
to rest afterwards totally I mean it
really is an adrenalin ride from start
to finish I would say that you know John
wick is this super assassin who is you
know the baddest guy in town and this
film places him with a fourteen million
dollar bounty on his head and all of the
other badass assassins in the world are
after him and so how does he deal with
that who are the characters that come
into his life in this film and and how
do they help or hinder you know his
ability to stay alive you know when your
characters aren't either an assassin or
working for an assassins like what what
is an average day look like for your
characters what do they do when they're
not assassins we were wondering about
this yeah I mean it's fun I well first
I'll say I'm like weary of developing a
backstory about the adjudicator that
turns out now to be true like in the
mind of Chad but I I feel like the
adjudicator spends a lot of time doing
things that are sort of like calm or
low-key like maybe a tea in the morning
taking some Sun maybe a crossword maybe
a puzzle you know because when they snap
to action they really snap to action and
zero zero is a martial arts teacher as
well so he's teaching as he's teaching
and training is Shinobi mm-hmm
how are you pet owners are either up you
pet owners how far would you go for your
pet I mean my children I know No thank
you that's whatever it takes
thank ya what was the sort of most
challenging scene to shoot in this film
did either of you get hurt making it
especially you mark get pretty crazy
oh thank you the finale
scene we shot that over a period of four
weeks I think and it was difficult
because one just it was you know it's
very intense and there's a lot of
choreography and you know you saw the
location that we're shooting at so that
alone is is difficult but to sustain
that type of focus and energy for such a
long time that's that's not easy to do
but Chad at the helm and Keanu with all
of us preparation and training they
brought it they brought it
you